- For a long time,
people were talking about
bullying and that was a big hot topic
and I think sometimes you can forget
that you could be your
own bully in some ways.
You don't have to be
born into a situation,
you don't have to come from something,
or possess something, or look flawless,
even though I like looking
like this sometimes.
If you can believe in something great,
I feel like you can
achieve something great.
- She's an American singer and songwriter.
She's one of the best
selling musicians of all time
having sold over 100
million albums worldwide.
Her estimated net worth is $125 million.
She's Katy Perry and here's my take
on her top ten rules of success.
Rule number five is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for a special bonus clip.
Also, as Katy is talking,
if she says something that
really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(blasting off)
(exploding)
(uptempo music)
- For a long time,
people were talking about
bullying and that was a big hot topic
and I think sometimes you can forget
that you could be your
own bully in some ways.
Like you are the person that is standing
in the way of your success,
whether it's professionally or personally,
and, honestly, that was the case for me.
I was having a great professional streak,
but personally I was really immature,
and so I had to balance them out.
Finally, I had enough and I said,
"Hey, you need to speak up for yourself.
"If you're not happy with something,
"you change it."
"Change it, make yourself
better every single day,
"so I went to a lot of therapy (laughs)
"and I guess I put it in the way of like
"'you're going to hear me wear,' finally,
"I'm going to be able
to speak up for myself."
This next record that I'll
start in a couple of months,
I think it'll be, actually, more honest
because I think when you get older,
you care less what people think about you
and I have had to really work on that.
I think that's one of the biggest things
you have to work on when you
are put into the spotlight
is not caring about what
people say about you
because you just become this open forum
to anybody, anything, anyone,
and if you start reading your own press,
it will ruin you.
I feel like I've got the opportunity
to make more of a career rather than
just like a flash in the pan,
she's hot, she's not type of thing,
but that's only because
I have worked so hard
and focused and everything I do,
I know it's for the fans
and they're the reason why I exist.
- Tell me about why you
decided to do this documentary.
- Oh, my goodness.
Well, I always liked to be honest
with everything I do, especially my songs.
I like to plant those
seeds of honesty and truth
because we live in a world
that doesn't have much of that left.
And with this documentary,
I wanted to show people
what was underneath the hood
and you can attest to that.
I've been under the hood many times.
(audience laughing)
I really wanted to show people
how much hard work it takes,
the ins and outs, and how, really,
you don't have to be
born into a situation,
you don't have to come from something,
or possess something, or look flawless,
even though I like looking
like this sometimes.
You can just be you and have a dream
and plant the seed and water the root.
I found a lot of self-love this year
and I rebuilt my confidence
that had had a little
bit of a shatter to it.
And I went inwards rather
than pointing the finger
on everyone else and blaming everyone
for my problems or the issues that I had.
I went inwards and tried
to do some patchwork.
To heal up little spots
that I needed to heal up
or say to myself, "What
can I do to make myself
"a better human representation--"
- What did you do?
- I did a lot of different things.
I did a cleanse for three months
that I didn't have any alcohol
and I did a whole vitamin regime
and I wen to therapy,
I did more mediation.
I've been meditating
for a couple years now,
but I upped it.
And I just went the positive route
rather than going to the club
and getting drunk every night (laughs).
I mean I've probably done
that a couple of times,
but I really serve myself well
and it influenced all of my songwriting
and I wrote most of the
songs during this time.
From the very beginning of
me getting into the industry,
I would be out and about
and I would hear girls
or actresses, or musicians, or whatever.
They would say, "Oh, no, I don't want
"to be in a relationship
"because I don't want to have to choose
"between being in a relationship
"and having a career,"
and I thought to myself (blows),
"When I find that person
"that's going to be my life partner,
"I won't ever have to choose
"because they'll be accepting of me
"completely for who I am."
Not me being able to
just do whatever I want,
necessarily, but they wont' be threatened
or have weird motives or whatever.
They will be accepting of me,
the things I love, the ambition,
what I aspire to be,
what I want to create.
They'll be accepting and supportive.
And then I started to realize,
"Oh, my God.
"That's not true.
"That fairytale that I had is
not true for me right now."
Yeah.
I don't want--
(exhaling)
- [Announcer] Okay, again, everyone.
(mumbles)
- I'll tell ya' the truth is that
I'm a romantic
and I believe in this fairytale
and in some ways I think
that's always been to my advantage
because if you can believe
in something great,
I feel like you can
achieve something great.
I have that same belief
system with everything
from career to my life,
my personal life, everything,
and I will do everything it takes
to not fail and I did everything it took,
but it still failed.
The bad that comes along with the good
is a journey and I learned
so much from that journey.
- Why did you decide to
come out with "Roar"?
There was that big countdown
and then "Roar" came out
and it was huge for you.
You broke your own records there.
Why was it "Roar" the first single?
- It was up for debate,
a couple of singles.
It was going to be "Roar" or another one
and we decided to go with "Roar"
because of the reaction I
was getting from my friends.
I use my friends as
guinea pigs.
As test guinea pigs
and I have a very eclectic
group of friends ranging from
DJs to artists to just moms (laughs)
and they all really agreed that "Roar"
was the best one and it
has that bouncy feel.
That 8th note feel, but
it also has this message
of finding your inner strength again
and letting that come out as a roar
and people related to it.
- Yeah, well, they really did--
- And there's something.
There's an intuitive thing that happens
inside of me and I've
always trust my intuition
when it comes to writing songs
and picking which songs
should come out as singles.
I've been on tour for a year
and before that, I did promo for my record
and my record almost
came out two years ago,
so I've been doing a lot of work for that
for the past couple years and I think
what would be most important for me
is to, at this moment, gather my thoughts
and live a little bit of life on my own
and not around a traveling circus
of a hundred people and have quiet moments
and ride my bike and
find my roots again.
That's what I always do in between records
is I go to a quiet place
and restore my soul.
(uptempo music)
I usually go back to my
hometown of Santa Barbara
and figure out what all of this means
and get away from the distraction
and feed my spirituality and feed my
music.
Listening to a lot of music and just
getting my feet planted
back on the ground again.
(uptempo music)
It's really important for me to live life,
absorb life, and have my own experiences,
so that I can go back to the drawing board
and have something authentic to say.
- Question to Katy Perry
via YouTube moderator.
How was life before
you became a celebrity?
Before your big break?
- He's got the creepy voice a little bit.
- That's okay.
We don't judge.
I could be creepy too.
I mean if you saw me in a purple wig
walking down the street
you'd be like, "Freak!"
Well, it was all about
the hustle and the bustle
and sometimes it was me tryin' to keep up
with the Jones', as they say.
I wanted to be seen like I was worth it
and so I was trying to always be
ready for a opportunity to present itself.
It was exciting.
It was a little bit not as
fast paced as it is now.
Things are just so fast
paced like lightning speed
and I know what I'm doing today
and I know what I'm doing, probably,
in six months to the date,
so it wasn't as scheduled,
but I think I had a little bit
more time on my hands,
but I think that maybe I might've gotten
into a little bit more trouble back then
because, what is it?
Idle hands are the devil's workshop
is what my parents said,
so now I really have
a lot to take care of,
but it was just about working on my craft
and making sure that it was perfect,
so that when finally I
would get that opportunity,
I'd be ready for it.
♫ This is the part of me
- [Interviewer] Do you
steal believe in love?
- Of course!
I'm going to let love
lead the way, always,
and I was born with this blind ambition
and it's gotten me here to this point
and I think that I'll stick to it.
So, yes.
Oh, mom!
- [Mom] Huh?
- You're on speakerphone
and I'm on the stage right now.
(audience cheering)
And we all just want to wish
you a happy Mother's Day!
(audience cheering)
- [Mom] You're my little feather.
- Okay.
(audience laughing)
- [Audience Member] What
did she say (laughs)?
- [Katy] I'm your little feather.
I love you, mom.
I have to continue with the show,
but I just wanted to wish
you happy Mother's Day.
- [Mom] Alright, I love you too.
See you soon.
Bye bye, everybody.
- [Katy] What?
- Bye bye, everyone.
- [Audience] Bye!
- Bye, mom.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you guys so much for watching!
I made this video because
unlimited traffic asked me to,
so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
please leave it down in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I also love to know what did you take
from Katy that had the
biggest impact on you.
What lesson are you going to apply
to your business or your life?
Please leave it in the comments
(mumbles) join in the discussion.
Also, want to give a quick shoutout
to my sister, Stefanie Carmichael.
Thank you so much for picking up a copy
of my book and also going to the bookstore
and rearranging it, so that
my book comes up first.
I really appreciate that.
Thanks for the love.
So, thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love.
I'll see ya' soon.
(blasting off)
(exploding)
(flying)
- Transcendental mediation, to me,
it's like a great workout
for your mind without working out,
but you get all the
effects of working out.
I come from a very spiritual world,
from a very religious upbringing,
and it's not religious,
it's not spiritual,
although I think if you're taking care
of you body, your mind,
that is a spiritual thing,
but it doesn't have that
religious background.
To me it's mostly medical and
it's like a little pill, but not a pill.
It's a practice, so it's a little
practice that you do and,
to me, it's the most rest.
It's the most power
nap you could ever get.
- And that experience of that quiet.
That is, they call it,
state of restful alertness,
according to science.
Where your mind is completely settled,
but you're wide awake
and it's before thoughts.
Someone said to me, "Well, how do you know
"when your 20 minutes are up?"
I said, "Well, you can
look at your watch."
It's not like you're going someplace,
but that peaceful state that you access
just happened quite effortlessly
and that's a wonderful description.
Oh, one more question.
How do you think it's impacted
your remarkable career?
- My life is so crazy.
It really is.
It's extreme.
I live in this one percentile extreme.
I'm zigzagging all over the world.
I'm on a plane more than I am on ground
and this tool helps me
find moments of peace
because I don't have a whole lot of time
that extend my day, so I can
live my fullest capacity.
It gives me two days in one day.
It just gives me this power.
And I do it before I
write a song sometimes,
definitely before I get on stage,
and it's just such an incredible, useful,
simple tool that has made
such an impact on me and that's why
I'm sitting here with you today.
- You're very calm on tour.
At least with me 'cause you invited
our whole team to come and
teach your team to meditate
and I ran into you, you're
coming out of a room
and we're just chatting and you looked
and you said, "Bob, there's
16,000 people waiting for me.
"Right around the corner."
And you just did that,
you were polite with me,
and you just waked out on the stage,
but there was such an evenness.
- I'm a multitasker (laughs).
- [Man] You have a great deal
of kindness inside of you.
- Thank you.
- You're a very kind person.
I think that it would be a shame
to have such a great cure all to yourself
like the cure for the common cold
and not to share it with people
that are suffering.
So, it's the cure for the common stress,
which stress is a killer these days
and I have a lot of it in my life
and I have a great tool
that helps subside it
and I want to share that
'cause I don't want people to suffer.
I like to lift people up.